mmm this is bad
a dirty flag and finally style
yes dirty flag Thank You men fangled
teaching the ways of life George Mayer
ooh what is this move
the v7 prevent
six gopher who he played Bishop a six
anyway today we have some London
what is going on a for maybe he's gonna
play 96 a night she for make it
interesting
f3 always playoff three so what kind
Feingold said right
he's still up on time despite my amazing
pre moving
but I have some attack maybe be three
I'll sack the pawn and then go for a
king side play I want to play Bishop
here next
mmm doesn't quite work by d5
does it work
mmm let's go for it I Brooke oh he did
something to me me
my dirty flag him again the last
opponent I have an outpost never resign
when you have an outpost
a knight for queen is gonna start taking
stuff those queen is blockading a very
strong pawn
how do I win this
he's thinking he is thinking I'm
fighting back here he's low on time too
on how do I win this
ooh where is my mate this
see
you
you
you
I'd be George Meyer down a queen that
was the best moment of my life next game
oh yeah never resigned when you have an
outpost I was beautiful I'm sorry George
my